thank you
the governing Council decided the
following
will continue to conduct net asset
purchases under the pandemic emergency
purchase program
with a total envelope of
1800 billion euros until at least the
end of March 22 and in any case
until the governing Council judges that
the coronavirus crisis phase is over
[Music]
Morning Joe yeah the European Central
Bank doing what uh economists thought
they were going to do they uh added to
their pandemic emergency purchase
program by 500 billion euros by my
account that takes it up to 1.85
trillion total
it is an absolutely historic week both
in terms of the speed of fed purchases
and of course the magnitude here's a
chart that shows what's happened since
the first of since the March the last
three weeks I've seen this huge ramp up
in a ways that you've never seen before
let's look at what's changed here uh
since the FED last met we got the 1.9
trillion dollars in relief enacted by
Congress signed by the president Senate
Democrats have just released the tax of
their 3.5 trillion dollar budget
resolution can you characterize
everything that the FED has done this
past week as essentially flooding the
system with money yes exactly and
there's no end to your ability to do
that there's no end to our ability to do
that simply flooded the system with
money
yes we did that's another way to think
about it we did where does it come from
do you just print it
we print it digitally so we you know we
as a central bank we have the ability to
create money
uh digitally and we do that by buying
treasury bills or bonds or other
government guaranteed Securities and
that that actually increases the money
supply we do believe that inflation
numbers in 21 which we will see Rising I
can't find any period in history
or monetary and fiscal policy we're this
out of step with the economic
circumstances not one in six weeks last
spring
we did more to a more more purchasing
treasuries than we did the entire time
the nine-year period from 2009 to 2018.
and if we ever get an inflationary
psychology like for instance we did when
I was in my 20s back in the 70s if we
ever get that again and if you ever got
retail actually nervous about inflation
then the one thing that leads inflation
which is commodity prices are one of the
it's the it's the easiest tautology
there is those things can literally
screen double or triple with no problem
whatsoever valuations for both interest
rates and stocks are at if you combine
the two they're they're so overvalued
they're at 100 Year highs I don't know I
don't know what you do I am so afraid of
a democracy getting the idea that you
can just print money to solve all
problems and eventually I know that will
fail at the end if you print too much
you end up in something like
Venezuela it's mathematics the fiat
currency is now the error term that
solves the growth in the numerator which
is your total Global debt versus the
denominator which is total Global GDP
and we have reached a point of no return
where the numerator is going to grow
outstrip the growth of the denominator
under any plausible scenario which means
you need to print money to solve that
debt spiral
foreign
[Music]
we've all heard of our economic cycles
and how according to most modern economy
books it is normal to have a period of
very quick growth and expansion followed
by a period of contraction and
economical crisis
as described in 1946 by Arthur F Behrens
former counselor to the president of the
United States and Wesley C Mitchell
American economist business Cycles are a
type of fluctuation found in the
aggregate economic activity of Nations a
cycle consists of expansions occurring
at about the same time in many economic
activities followed by similarly General
recessions this sequence of changes is
recurrent but not periodic
history though shows us that before the
20th century financial crisis arrived
because of external events the most
popular being War
there had been only one financial crisis
not attributable to external events and
this was the Panic of 1825 where around
70 Banks went bankrupt due to risky
Investments and because of this man
Gregor McGregor that had pulled big
investments into colonizing a country
that didn't exist hoyes
if we look at history what
turns out what we find out is the fact
that
this cycle really started about a
hundred years ago and there's an
important factor to that it's the fact
that in the year 1914 every big nation
in the world just started leaving the
gold standard now the gold standard is
the fact that all of the money that a
central bank
has controls or produces is only based
on the amount of gold that they Halt and
the price of gold
therefore the amount of money supply
available is relative to the gold that
is held this was dropped and this is
what led to a lot of financing for the
first world war and even following the
second world war because governments
realize that they have this huge power
that is get rid of the gold standard and
we can just print money as much as we
want and in fact this happens many times
in history and was often the reason why
governments countries or civilizations
were simply dropping the Roman Empire is
a great example of that from the moment
we dropped this gold standard so around
the year 1940 the UK was the first
country to do that this is the moment
where we started seeing uh these
short-term and long-term Cycles
particularly the short-term Cycles we
are now over 100 years after leaving the
gold standard and it is a fairly
accepted fact that our economy Works in
Cycles based on a period of inflation
followed by a period of deflation the
fact this only started a hundred years
ago should tell you that our monetary
system has flaws over being the reason
for the unmatched growth we had as a
species in the 20th century
foreign
is due to our Reliance on debt and
credit according to Modern monetary
Theory depth is the driver of economic
growth not productivity Ray dalio
explains this well in his video how the
economic machine works over time we
learn and that accumulated knowledge
raises our living standards we call this
productivity growth
those who are inventive and hard-working
raise their productivity and their
living standards faster than those who
are complacent and lazy
but that isn't necessarily true over the
short run productivity matters most in
the long run but credit matters most in
the short run this is because
productivity growth doesn't fluctuate
much so it's not a big driver of
economic swings debt is because it
allows us to consume more than we
produce when we acquire it and it forces
us to consume less than we produce when
we have to pay it back and as stated by
Dylan declare in his great article the
conclusion of the long-term debt cycle
and the rise of Bitcoin although
productivity is the most important
aspect of an economic system over the
long term not productivity but the
forces of debt are the main driving
forces in volatile economic swings
coming back to the Cycles breakdano
describes the long term and the
short-term death cycle and how they
relate to human productivity death
swings occur in two big Cycles one takes
about five to eight years and the other
takes about 75 to 100 years While most
people feel the swings they typically
don't see them as Cycles because they
see them too up close day by day week by
week the short-term debt cycle can be
observed by looking at different metrics
including the debt to income ratios and
interest rates set by the Central Bank
yes the Central Bank essentially sets
the rules that allow our economy to
expand into unreasonable debt and later
decides when it can break down this is
the so-called boom and bus cycle the
most recent ones being the global
financial crisis of 2008 and the.com
bubble of the year 2000.
the long-term debt cycle is made of
multiple short-term Cycles while our
economy goes up and down during each of
these Cycles it does bring growth in the
long run and with each cycle our economy
continues accumulating debt indefinitely
because we prefer borrowing than
repaying debt there reaches a moment
when there is more debt to pay than
income
historically this is when the long-term
debt cycle shifts people stopped
spending and start repaying debt and
instead of growing we go down we see
recessions increase government support
devaluation of currencies social unrest
and so on
there comes a time when our economy has
sufficiently deleveraged and the economy
starts growing again following the
short-term debt cycle again
during these deleveraging events three
strategies are adopted by central banks
first lower the interest rates interest
rates are set by central banks and
they set the rules as to what is the
cost of borrowing money if they lower it
then it's cheaper to borrow money
therefore people will be more inclined
to borrow this money and this this leads
to the spiral of just wanting to borrow
more and more and more because it's just
easier to borrow and and right now if we
look at the numbers the Central Bank
central banks all over the world have
been doing this for years now because we
work on a standard that is mostly based
on the US dollar what matters is uh is
what the U.S Central Bank does and if
they lower interest interest rates then
everyone else will also lower their
interest rates this increases the value
of assets and makes it easier to get
credits
this is the first strategy used today
these interest rates have already
dropped drastically for the main
economies and have turned negative in
many
if interest rates dropped zero then
there is no logical Financial incentive
to lend money it can continue for a
while until it doesn't
second there is quantitative easing also
called money printing what this guy was
talking about it allows the central bank
to buy debt Securities and financial
assets it places cash in the hand of
investors but doesn't help citizens
asset prices Skyrocket usually creating
inflation which makes asset holders that
tend to be the wealthy richer and the
poor poorer as their savings lose value
this is the case today with real estate
skyrocketing globally and other raw
materials skyrocketing too
third and last is increased welfare
spending or other instruments such as
stimulus payments
if there is any kind of Crisis well the
people about their house they're not
going to try and do any more financial
um
schemes the things that would allow them
to to protect their investment because
they just don't have all the knowledge
or the skills and even the instruments
to be able to do that so they're the
ones that lose the most right because
investment Banks they know what's coming
they know how to deal with it and
they'll get out of it but this creates
basically
a gap between the rich and the poor and
this is a lot due to money printing
because this money
um gets uh distributed into the economy
but it doesn't get distributed into the
hands of people it gets uh paid to Banks
it gets paid to to investors and it just
gives them another business and it gives
them more cash to be able to take on
more positions and themselves invest
into many different assets whether it's
Stock Exchange can be Gold Anything the
poor people don't have these options and
they don't have this money directly
attributed to them so it means that like
well all of this is happening and people
are getting rich others are getting
poorer because the savings that they
have in the bank are losing value
because of this this money Printing and
because of that what governments need to
do is they need to help their citizens
more because of course no one wants a
wealth Gap I mean it's not because
you're you know part of this Elite let's
say that that is uh in a better position
financially that um you want the poor
people to be in a bad situation like
everyone has to be elevated in society
and these people need to be helped
directly uh through financing uh
whatever form it takes and and in fact
if you look at the numbers it's since
the crisis of 1929 which was the first
big financial crisis after getting off
the gold standard that I was mentioning
at the beginning that this welfare
spending has increased so much and now
in France for example there's above 30
percent of GDP that goes to welfare
spending France is quite famous for that
it has one of the best medical systems
but it also goes with how you support
people that are unemployed uh different
stimulus payments help for a home
allowances and and this kind of thing
that it that is of course good for
people that need it but is only
necessary because of these actions that
are taken beforehand
more recently we know social spending
has increased due to the covet crisis so
we can only presume that the chart now
looks more like this
we are seeing another measure increasing
quickly the monetary Supply
monetary Supply is the total amount of
one currency that is currently available
in the economy
the more a government creates new money
the more the supply increases this money
supply is directly correlated to the
devaluation of our currencies
many like to inverse these charts in
order to show this devaluation because
the more a currency is produced the less
it is scarce therefore the more it loses
value we have all heard stories from our
elders saying money had a different
value back then and I've seen archive
images illustrating this like this
McDonald's menu from 1972 that had a Big
Mac for 65 cents
the increase in money supply is the
reason why this happens
in 2020 alone the money supply has had a
big jump
the money that was printed in order to
finance the war against covid and in the
US since the beginning of 2020 we have
seen an increase of over 30 percent in
the amount of US dollars in circulation
although this isn't felt instantly in
the economy the long-term effects will
be found by the population that have
zero allocation in assets such as real
estate stocks and so on the long-term
consequences of this are very white
to illustrate take technology by
definition technology should drop in
price because it becomes more efficient
and easier to produce yet due to
inflation prices are not going down
essentially making it harder to develop
new technologies
governments use many reasons including
climate change as an excuse to print
trade it but down the road this printing
can lead to adverse results because of
the effects this new monetary Supply can
have on the development of the right
technologies that could help us
transition to a more renewable energy
consuming world
but the central banks will have a
different message this is in order to
avoid the spread of panic concerning the
financial markets and their currencies
which could lead people to rush to bank
to withdraw their money this obviously
would be unsustainable for the economy a
nation in which faith in a currency is
lost will see recessions and will take
decades to recover
instead central banks use the Consumer
Price Index also called the CPI the CPI
is a flood indicator yet is the most
commonly accepted indicator to measure
inflation and its effects on prices
the CPI follows the price of a basket of
products that are consumed by people
this in essence is the way an indicator
like this one should work
but the CPI is flawed because of the way
this basket of products is selected it
is selected based on what people choose
to buy
so every year new products will be added
to this basket While others will be
removed
but what they choose to buy depends on
the price of the product if inflation
goes up people will change their basket
of products in order to accommodate for
the price increase this essentially
makes it a new basket of products the
CPI will not track the price of the
previous basket of products it will
track the price of the new basket of
products after the consumer decision has
been made in response to price increases
safer in Amazon illustrates this
properly in the Fiat standard
imagine you earn 10 a day and spend them
all on eating a delicious ribeye steak
that gives you all the nutrients you
need for the day
in this simple consumer basket of goods
the CPI is 10 dollars
now imagine one day hyperinflation
strikes the economy and the price of
your rib eye increases to a hundred
dollars while your daily wage remains
ten dollars
what happens to the price of your basket
of goods
it cannot rise tenfold because you
cannot afford the hundred dollar ribeye
instead you make do with the chemical
shitstorm that is a soy burger for ten
dollars
Pi magically shows zero inflation
remember that governments will never
show us the true inflation numbers and
they will not attribute it to the
increase in our monetary Supply because
of their management if people actually
understood this they would never be
re-elected
[Music]
we've talked about depth so much it is
time to look at these numbers too we can
see the sharp increase of the global
debt even in just the most recent years
to add more context here is what this
debt represents as share of global GDP
356 percent
we have 3.5 times more debt than actual
created value
now this dead bubble could be stopped or
at least be slowed down if the central
banks were to increase interest rates
making it more expensive to borrow
giving a breather to the entire system
but today it's likely too late the US
Central Bank the FED attempted this in
2018 because they believe the economy
looked to have recovered from the global
financial crisis of 2007.
10 years have now passed since the
depths of the financial crisis
a painful part of our history that cost
many Americans their jobs their homes
and for some their hopes and dreams
in addition to holding interest rates
low to support the recovery we've also
taken many steps to make the financial
system safer
I'm confident that this system today is
stronger and in a far better position to
support the financial needs of
households and businesses
through good times and bad they decide
to increase these interest rates and
because of that the entire Market
dropped in the space of a couple weeks
and NASDAQ and the S P 500 dropped over
20 percent
in just a couple weeks only because the
markets were reacting to these actions
that were done by the by the Central
Bank the Dow is moving back towards the
lows of the day all 30. Dow stocks are
now in the red and the Dow's gains for
the year are gone a distant memory the S
P 500 has fallen into correction that's
a drop of 10 percent or more from recent
highs all sectors and this is key are in
the red at this moment and the NASDAQ is
now at a seven month low look at the CNN
business fear and greed index yeah I
know you don't want to see it we got to
give it to you it measures volatility
momentum and demand for safe havens it's
pointing to extreme fear so as soon as I
started dropping the the Central Bank
came publicly and said okay we're gonna
stop this we're going to go back to a
normal normal level of interest rates
and uh and from that moment on by the
end in 2019 they started again lowering
these interest rates and they lowered
them from all the way 2.5 percent to now
0.25 percent according to a lot of
Finance books and what people study at
University the scenario we're in today
with negative interest rates is
impossible right so what happens then
it's hard to say no one no one really
knows what kind of have to have to find
out because anyway central banks have no
other option the only thing they can do
is print more money foreign
Ty the only thing that the central banks
can do is print more money and cover for
all the steps that is never being paid
back
they will work with governments to
continue increasing taxes welfare
spending and evaluating currency this
isn't to say that these people are ill
intended they use the tools that are
available to them and have simply
reached a point where their backs are
against the wall and they are forced to
abuse these tools
[Music]
and they are looking for solutions to
take the entire economy out of this
situation although these Solutions are
not necessarily in the best interest of
citizens and their personal freedom it
isn't without reason that the world
economics Farms initiative is called the
Great reset the name that inspired this
documentary
part of their plan is the creation of
Central Bank digital currencies
cbdc's this would allow central banks to
have a new monetary system that they can
detach from the current one allowing
people to transition into this new
debt-free system and slowly deleveraging
and dropping the depth from the previous
one without adding risk to their
currencies so Central Bank digital
currency is coming alive uh it's it's
not going to happen today I think they
have a 12-month experimental period but
they want to to go through before they
actually launch for good the status of
it is we're working hard on it right now
but let me tell you what it what it is
really we're going to address
digital payments broadly so that means
stable coins it means it means crypto
assets it means a cbdc that whole group
of that of of issues and and payment
mechanisms which we think are are really
at a critical uh point would you say
that the corona crisis has even
um revealed more the need to have a
digital Central Bank currency or
currencies
well yes I think I think Corona the
corona crisis
has accelerated very much technical
change and use of digital Innovations
across the board I mean it's not only in
financial transactions protein
e-commerce and the show business I mean
there are so many examples that you know
but yes it is a factor pretty much all
central banks are thinking about this in
the last few weeks of 2020
um The People's Bank of China rolled out
a pilot program in the Eastern Chinese
city of Suzhou they had to download an
app and and have it on the phone in a
macro way you have a sense of how money
flows through the economy on a micro
scale and this is something that many in
the west would probably not be
comfortable with and many in China
frankly would not be comfortable with is
that it would allow authorities to be
able to track precisely how you or my
neighbor or the person down the street
they're spending the money or they're
spending the money on buying things they
shouldn't be buying whatever however you
define that are they are they gambling
with their money are they doing this or
that with the money they say it's just
to replace physical cash but of course
this could just be the first step
adoption will come for these cbdcs in
fact it will be first adoption
the government will start supporting
citizens in Need by only giving them
stimulus payments to reward it
controlled directly by the central bank
the central bank will essentially be
able to eliminate commercial banks that
are currently the middleman between the
central bank and the citizens
for governments it will simplify many
things if they decide to change interest
rates they will be able to act on it
directly rather than wait the several
months needed for commercial Banks to
implement this in their systems they
will also be able to control directly
the interest rates based on a person's
profile or a business's profile and will
be able to set expiry dates on people's
money forcing them to spend and not
allowing them to save
Raul Paul describes this well
you see central banks want to be able to
give people money directly Direct
monetization
they can't do that right now right now
they print money goes into the banking
system the banks hoard it because we're
going to a credit crunch it's also a way
for them to kick-start Universal basic
income because the central bank can
under can underpin the poorer parts of
society by giving them money directly it
doesn't go on the government balance
sheet now central banks now believe
they're omnipotent that they can
continue to expand balance sheets
forever mmt seems to be the prevalent
thought and this is just an extension of
this this is kind of Keynesian
keynesianism gone mad central banks can
also
change entirely the structure of
how money and monetary policy works and
fiscal policy because they can give it
to different people in different ways
so they can credit the restaurateur but
then penalize with negative interest
rates the baby boomer saver because they
want to release their money back into
the economy
they can give students a positive
interest rates to help them save they
can change everything
this is the rise of Behavioral economics
and incentive systems
so governments essentially using big
data can find who they need to stimulate
at any time and adjust accordingly they
can do it dynamically this is a a
structural massive shift to everything
we understand about economics
particularly macroeconomics
nobody's prepared for this none of us
know what this means it means and it
will be sold on a load of good things
and I think there's a lot of good things
that come from this I think it is an
elegant solution to some of our problems
but elegant Solutions in governments and
central banks lead to unintended
consequences
the issue is here is to have this new
system you're going to give up your
freedom
you are going to have every transaction
you've ever done and ever will do
recorded there is no cash
there is no way of tipping the gardener
unless it goes by cash
it means that they can tax you at every
transaction level now that's great we
could get rid of the IRS and all of the
tax collection agencies because it could
be done directly
that's good
but again you've lost your freedom to
transact in anonymity that cash gives
you
these are Central Bank digital
currencies as I said they're not um
they're not an invention from from
governments and central banks in fact
they're inspired by
um other digital currencies like Bitcoin
being the original one and other
altcoins that have been created after
that in reality they are more similar to
other altcoins such as ethereum or
others that simply allow the addition of
programming that allows you to add
functionalities to them whereas Bitcoin
is uh is only there for these monetary
transfers Bitcoin is uh is is a payment
Network right where there's uh um think
of it as a log of transactions a
transactions that I can do to you the
Bitcoin network will take some
information so my address your address
the amount of Bitcoin that I'm sending
to you and with this information it's
gonna it's gonna create a hash it just
goes through a simple hashing algorithm
that makes a code out of this
information and this is added to this to
this log whatever amounts that happen
within these 10 minutes basically is
considered a block and there be miners
so computers that are connected to the
network to verify these transactions so
they're just going to be there ready to
confirm that I do have this Bitcoin and
yes I can send it to you and that after
that I no longer have this Bitcoin and
you have the Bitcoin so very simple kind
of work but all of these computers are
connected to the network and they're in
competition fighting for who confirms
the block because whoever confirms the
block and verifies these transactions
will be will be rewarded in Bitcoin from
from two sources there'll be a
transaction cost simply if I send you
Bitcoin then I pay a certain fee to the
network this fee will be redistributed
to Miners and also right now there is a
an emission of new Bitcoin so
um today it's at 6.25 Bitcoins per block
and if I as a miner I'm able to confirm
this block I will receive 6.25 Bitcoin
it won't happen every time because
there's a big competition of miners 6.25
Bitcoin per block every 10 minutes
that's quite a bit especially if you
think of the price of Bitcoin today
Bitcoin is built in a way there is an
entire incentive uh scheme that has been
thought out by the creator of Bitcoin
that goes all the way to the year
2140 or so
um which is that the amount of Bitcoins
that are produced will be divided every
four years by two so if I'm a minor
today I make 6.25 Bitcoin per block that
I confirm four years from now after the
next halving it'll be half that so 3.12
uh Bitcoin this is an incentive for
um the for people to be as efficient as
possible when running their their
Bitcoin mining business and also an
incentive for the price to stay above
certain certain level because miners
simply will either run out of business
if the price is too low
um or we'll decide not to sell his
Bitcoin because he's not covering for
his operating expenses
in the Bitcoin protocol changes can be
made in two ways there's a simple way
called A Hard Fork where someone
essentially makes a copy of Bitcoin
makes changes to the protocol and
releases it to the world miners need to
connect to this new network and choose
to use this new network over the
original Bitcoin Network
this was done by projects such as
Bitcoin cash and Bitcoin Satoshi Vision
they were trying to solve what the
founders thought to be problems in the
Bitcoin Network there was a scaling
attempt to allow Bitcoin to continue to
be money for the world it was called the
segwit 2x agreement where segwit which
is if you're deep into crypto you
already know what that is if not don't
worry about it and the block size were
going to be upgraded from one megabyte
to two megabytes which would uh if you
do both those things you're gonna get
more than double as many transactions
available on the Bitcoin network if you
do uh just the two one megabyte two
megabyte you double add segwit it's a
little bit more on top of that anyhow
for for whatever reason the segwit
portion of that agreement was activated
first when that two megabyte upgrade
eventually was aborted uh I had to look
around the world and say okay well if I
want a tool that can enable every human
being on the planet to be able to send
and receive any amount of money with any
other human being on the planet Bitcoin
can't do that it's not going to do that
with one megabyte blocks it's impossible
for Bitcoin to do that so there's a
whole bunch of other cryptocurrencies
out there which one do I think is the
most likely to bring the most economic
freedom to the most people around the
world in the shortest amount of time and
I looked at all the different
cryptocurrencies out there and Bitcoin
cash was the one that was at the top of
my list
since their launch these projects have
failed compared to bitcoin losing value
against the first cryptocurrency because
the people that are positioned in
Bitcoin didn't want to transition
this reluctant was mostly due to one
reason decentralization
decentralization in Bitcoin is the fact
that no one controls the network
it is an open secure network controlled
and improved by every participant
in projects like Bitcoin cash the number
of participants being much lower than in
Bitcoin lowered the security
Bitcoin Satoshi vision is a great
example as it was the victim of a 51
attack in 2021 a minus performance is
based on the amount of computational
power they have and this is usually
referred to as hash rate or hashing
power the mining power is distributed
over different nodes across the world
which means it is not in the hands of a
single entity at least it is not
supposed to be
but what happens when the hash rate is
no longer distributed well enough what
happens if one single entity is able to
obtain more than 50 of the hashing power
one possible consequence of that is what
we call a 51 attack also known as a
majority attack
a 51 attack is a potential attack on the
blockchain network where a single entity
or organization is able to control the
majority of the hash rate potentially
causing a network disruption in such a
scenario the attacker would have enough
mining power to intentionally exclude or
modify the ordering of transactions they
could also reverse transactions they
made while being in control leading to a
double spending problem
a successful majority attack could also
allow the attacker to prevent some or
all transactions from being confirmed or
to prevent miners from mining resulting
in what is known as mining Monopoly the
second method to make changes is called
a soft fork in a soft Fork changes are
made to the protocol and need to be
accepted by the majority of miners
to do so miners simply decide whether
they want to upgrade to the new protocol
and update their machines and eventually
if approved by the majority of miners at
a predetermined block number the changes
will be made official and this is how
miners will verify blogs from that point
on
unlike many other protocols every change
that is made to the Bitcoin Network
needs to be backwards compatible this
means that if someone holds Bitcoin
their Bitcoin will still be valid after
the changes
other networks may be easier to change
but won't be backwards compatible and
will often require holders of the coin
to transfer their coins to platforms
that will accept the changes before a
certain date or risk losing everything
there will be a maximum and this is
hard-coded a maximum of 21 million
Bitcoin produced by the year at 2140 and
there will never be more of it
so we can't afford to lose some Bitcoin
simply based on a a bug fixer a
functionality implementation is just
something that cannot work therefore
every change has to be backwards
compatible and this makes it so much
more difficult to change as opposed to
other projects that don't care much
because they have a management team that
is there that will decide which New
Vision they have for this coin and will
make updates regardless of what the
community thinks because they think it's
what's in the best interest of the
community
the fact Bitcoin is so difficult to
change is one of the reasons that make
it a great asset for the long run
buyers know what they're buying and they
know that the asset will remain the same
no other Assets in the world provides
this level of security other
cryptocurrencies have been created but
were created by a group of people that
still control the network and will make
changes to profit themselves
ethereum for example the second biggest
cryptocurrency by market cap is still
controlled by the same team that created
it
these people control the network and
promote the network in order to bring an
experienced and non-technical investors
that don't understand what a lack of
decentralization means for the future of
cryptocurrencies
the ethereum network aims to change the
way the protocol works these changes
will allow miners to mine only if they
have log 32 ether beforehand
anyone can mine Bitcoin with mine
ethereum you will soon need to be part
of the few in the world that can afford
to buy 32 ether
this will make ethereum just as good a
currency as a fiat currency
because the decisions of a few will
impact the masses
[Music]
thank you
think of Bitcoin the asset and the
network as the layer one there are other
layers that are being built around it
they're called layer twos and also layer
threes but the the fastest growing in
Layer Two for Bitcoin is called the
lightning Network and it's a it's a
different payment system that to use it
basically I need to take some of my
Bitcoin and you know actually put it
onto the bit onto the lightning Network
and I need to open channels if I open a
Channel with you for example it means I
can transfer money to you and the fact
that I have this channel open with you
means that I have access to the channels
that you have open yourself
and it scales very quickly in the sense
that if we both use the lightning
Network and we have a channel open
between the two of us then you have
access to all of my contacts and you can
pay them and I have access to all the
viewers and you can pay that payments
that I do will go through the channels
of maybe multiple people
in order to reach uh its destination and
this allows for payments to actually be
instant instant settlement this doesn't
exist in finance up until now and
they're free or almost free in most
cases
just because of how the the this network
is built and only once I would bring
this money out of the lightning Network
and back into the Bitcoin main network
is the transaction actually done inside
of this main Network
um which means that you can do a lot
more transactions a much faster and
cheaper
but still having Bitcoin as the
settlement layer that will confirm that
all of this happens basically
[Music]
the adverse environmental impact of the
Computing activity used to Mint many of
these digital currencies in the first
place
Bitcoin consumes more energy than entire
countries and it is projected to consume
as much energy as all the data centers
in the whole world this year
one Bitcoin transaction a single
purchase sale or transfer uses the same
amount of electricity as the typical U.S
household uses in more than a month
bitcoin's main layer is described as
being very energy consuming and it is a
fact that it's its highest in May 2021
the Bitcoin network was using as much
energy as with the entire country of
Sweden uses
although this seems like a lot we need
to break down what this energy is where
it comes from and how this trend is
evolving including where the big miners
are transferring to in order to lower
their costs and environmental impact
first of all it is important to
understand how a minor business is set
up
these miners are businesses the more
important ones today being International
companies listed on stock exchanges
setting up a mining business requires
the purchase of Hardware the Asic
computers needed to tap into the Bitcoin
Network and start mining as well as real
estate to store all of the miners
wherever miners are around the world the
price is for these two elements will
often be similar of course better deals
can be negotiated but given the price of
electrical components and supply chain
costs this isn't where miners will often
gain an edge over their competition what
matters most to minors is energy
everything factor and this is the most
important one is the energy that they
that they spend in order to make their
mining rigs turn the prices vary between
countries they vary between region and
they vary on the source of energy that
they choose the cheapest source is right
now always renewable energies or nuclear
but nuclear is a bit killed by
governments so these companies by
default they have to direct themselves
and push for the development of these
more renewable energies because it will
cost them cheaper in the long term cheap
energy can be found from two sources
green energy and wasted energy
the energy we produce is always in
excess we never consume a hundred
percent of the energy produced by power
plants because it would put communities
at risks of having blackouts in the U.S
it is estimated that five to six percent
of the energy produced is lost when it
is in transit which is around 211
terawatt hours
this amount alone is close to double
what Bitcoin was consuming at its
all-time high
nowadays governments are pushing for the
adoption of solar and wind power and
decide to crack down on nuclear
unfortunately although on paper this
sounds positive there are adverse
effects to this
with our current Technologies the energy
produced cannot be stocked therefore the
energy from solar and wind can only be
produced when it is sunny or windy
this makes it very unreliable and
requires backup power plants to be
present and active on a daily basis to
cover for this lack of energy
this really is an adverse effect because
Germany for example the biggest adapter
of solar in wind in Europe is now back
to producing the same amount of CO2
levels as it was producing 20 years ago
green policies around the world have
stopped the adoption of nuclear power
plants and have indirectly forced the
world to consume more natural gas than
it used to
natural gas comes with its own set of
problems
just like other energy sources natural
gas is produced more than it is consumed
which leads to flaring
flaring is simply the excess gas that is
extracted that needs to be burned it is
a standard and unnecessary Habit in the
industry in 2019 alone it is estimated
that 150 billion cubic meters of natural
gas was flared in the world
this is the same amount as Japan and
Korea imported that same year
all gone in the air producing
approximately 300 million tons of CO2
same as the total annual emissions of
Italy
[Music]
in order to lower their cost and energy
miners are directly connecting to these
sources of energy that until now were
inaccessible
because Bitcoin miners can be placed
anywhere in the world without the need
of being close to communities they are
already tapping directly into this
energy because of the attractive prices
they can negotiate with the producers
using energy that would otherwise be
flared or would be lost due to Transit
they also have access to more distant
natural sources of energy that cannot be
used by communities
this is the case of hydropower plants
geothermal energy and even new ideas
that are being studied like getting
energy from volcanoes
the more time passes and the more these
businesses grow the more likely they
will transition to these sources of
energy in order to increase their
profits other businesses are working on
innovating our energy production to
service miners allowing them to have
clean and cheap energy
the long-term positive effects the
adoption of Bitcoin could have on our
energy production is largely
underestimated and even silenced by
governments and other mainstream Medias
they may use this as an argument but it
is so little if you compare it to what
energy is actually used around the world
and if you compare it to also to the
energy used by our traditional Financial
Services Banks and so on they use way
more energy because each of them need to
create their own settlement
infrastructure
separately of course because they don't
share this information with anyone
whereas Bitcoin is just one place where
all of this happens right in an
uncontrolled and so on so it's a little
bit of energy consumed for
a huge impact in terms of
Financial Freedom and freedom in general
actually
Bitcoin was created by a person or a
group of people under the Alias Satoshi
Nakamoto
they wrote the white paper built the
network released it and exchanged in
discussions on many forums before one
day disappearing
a genius unknown person put together
Technologies and encryption protocols in
a new way forming the ultimate currency
and then did the most noble and
important step of all disappeared after
creating it talking about it publicly on
forums
promoting the idea discussing it making
improvements or setting up the original
miners there's just a point in time when
the community also started to take over
it that this this person Satoshi
Nakamoto just just disappeared stopped
answering on any kind of forum started
stopped writing anything and even since
that point the creation of Bitcoin never
touched the Bitcoin that were on these
original wallet addresses that were
created by Him
so completely let it go to the community
because the whole point of it was to get
rid of the control of our current
financial and monetary system and let it
be opened to the people so Bitcoin is
said to have been created by the people
for the people because of that because
it's controlled by a community not by a
central Authority anyone can participate
in improving the network whether it is
through translations code reviews or by
building applications that add
functionality to bitcoin
but only the Bitcoin core team can
actually make changes to the Bitcoin
Network and I think a huge part a part
of governance in the Bitcoin ecosystem
is the are the Bitcoin core developers
now uh before I met them and I've had
the pleasure and the honor of of meeting
uh many of them uh you know that was
that was a part of this ecosystem I
didn't understand but actually getting
to sit down and talk to them uh I uh if
I if I have a learning curve need it
certainly is on the technology side but
in in terms of talking to them about
economics economic theory failed
monetary regimes uh historically they
know economic history many of them
better than anyone I've ever met so that
gives me a great degree of confidence
that uh you know they they do believe
they they're on a noble Mission they
could be paid a lot more than they're
being paid right now if they worked at
Google or or Facebook or some of these
other areas but they've chosen you know
this sense of purpose if they're a noble
goal and uh they have incredibly strong
technology backgrounds uh so as well as
a good understanding of economic history
especially monetary history and it gives
me a great deal of comfort as I think
about the governments of the ecosystem
uh much much more so than I I think we
would find in other Financial ecosystems
gold was considered always the what is
called hard money in fact the word hard
money comes from the fact that gold is
physical and hard just like sounds money
comes from the fact that you when you
hit gold there's sounds right so it was
always considered this hardest money now
Bitcoin follows the same rules but they
are strictly enforced by the protocol
um which makes it a better form of gold
so not only a better form of money but a
better firm of gold gold has been
controlled by government I've mentioned
this at the beginning when it comes to
removing the gold standard but gold uh
also then and during the second world
war
um for example in the UK people were not
allowed to hold gold personally the same
happened in the US in in the 70s
you had to sell your gold to the
government because the government needed
to increase its reserves this has
happened historically and if any bad
situation were to happen like it has
happened in the past the same thing
would happen I mean we're here today in
Poland whatever purchase of gold you do
in Poland
your personal information has to be
given to the government saying how much
gold you own so that they know where
they can come knock at your door if ever
they just need to increase their gold
reserves and don't have the cash to buy
it themselves it's so much easier to
confiscate them in the past seven years
there's been an average of one
international monetary crisis every year
now who gains from these crises not the
Working Man not the investor not the
real producers of wealth
the gainers are the international money
speculators
because they thrive on crises they help
to create them
in recent weeks the speculators have
been waging an all-out war on the
American dollar
[Music]
strength of a nation's currency is based
on the strength of that nation's economy
and the American economy is by far the
strongest in the world
accordingly I have directed the
Secretary of the Treasury to take the
action necessary to defend the dollar
against the speculators
I have directed secretary Conley to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar in the gold or other
Reserve assets except in amounts and
conditions determined to be in the
interest of monetary stability and in
the best interest of the United States
Bretton Woods established an arrangement
whereby supposedly from 1945 and the end
of the war onward
all currencies were convertible to the
dollar and the dollar to gold at that
time gold reserves were the final
mechanism for settling balance of
payments deficits but Bretton Woods
forestalled this process by permitting
the
sole Reserve currency the main Reserve
currency to be considered as official
Reserves for foreign central banks
such that they could settle all their
their deficits in dollars as opposed to
Gold that's the fundamental difference
between the classical gold standard and
what is called the gold exchange
standard which Bretton Woods enshrined
in law and in treaty in 1971
both Britain and several other countries
decided to and cash their huge
accumulations of dollar reserves under
the Bretton Woods system for gold and of
course President Nixon in his own way
decided to Trump them
[Music]
thank you
George says as long as we do not have
convertibility
he says the Europeans can't do all that
much to us I can't because he says when
we have convertibility then they had a
right to lecture us about what we ought
to do but with convertibility without
convertibility that that is not the case
these countries had the right to claim
gold
to redeem their dollar Reserves
it would put the United States in a
position of insolvency we just shouldn't
get all that excited about the fact that
they worry about our budget is that your
view exactly right they can't do one
cockeyed thing and they'll say oh well
we've got to maintain our relation we've
asked four dollars I said no we didn't
have the whole dollars there's hell
dollars it's been in their interest at
Old dollars that's right and I said uh
hell with them I am I'm not worried
about them I'm worried about us that's
right uh 19 1960s was filled with
financial crises that involved the
dollar but the total collapse came in
1971. he issued an executive order on
August 15 1971 and said I'm sorry we're
not paying our debts
we're certainly not paying our debts in
gold
to our friends abroad including the many
responsible members of the international
banking Community who are dedicated to
stability in the flow of trade I give
this assurance
the United States has always been and
will continue to be a forward-looking
and trustworthy trading partner and full
cooperation with the international
monetary fund and those who trade with
us we will press for the necessary
reforms to set up an urgently needed new
international monetary system
to this day gold can only be traded on
the markets during weekdays because some
people have decided this
with Bitcoin no one can make such
decisions
individual exchanges could but would be
losing against their competition
governments have no way of knowing
whether people own any it is the safest
way to hold wealth that is native to the
internet therefore is available always
everywhere
no assets in history has ever been this
easy to acquire allowing anyone with an
internet connection to tap into the
network anonymously and be able to
access their assets the same way
regardless of their geographic location
again anonymously
this is scary to governments they
understand that if people step away from
Fiat currencies new debt that is
necessary to generate inflation and to
devaluate currencies won't be created
following the same rules
this puts there and their Elite friends
entire status quo at risk
that's why they're afraid of it and
that's why they they try to kill it in
fact in China just this year they banned
any Bitcoin mining
and they closed any kind of Exchange
which is uh if you think as a
totalitarian government is a great
strategy if you think of freedom for
people it is not and they're not the
only ones this uh this year also the UK
has been attacking hard they've banned a
lot of Bitcoin ads on buses or on uh the
subway just all of these ads that we're
promoting Bitcoin have been strayed off
banned by the government they have put
pressure on on Commercial Banks as well
to block transfers from UK citizens and
UK bank accounts to crypto exchanges so
that they cannot basically leave the
British pound and buy Bitcoin instead
right so not only are they scared but
they're actually taking action to later
Implement their own Central Bank digital
currencies if you don't have Bitcoin
they give you this alternative well you
go for this alternative you have no
choice the reason they want to ban
Bitcoin is because they know the power
that it has and they know that would
take this power away from governments as
long as governments control the money
they can make decisions that citizens
don't agree with or don't realize will
have an impact on them whether direct or
indirect
as long as governments control the money
they can continue their Monopoly on
violence
Bitcoin was created 12 years ago after
the global financial crisis as a
solution to the financial problems that
exist in our economy and to eliminate
entirely the abuse people can have on
our monetary system
Amos says it it's important to
understand that the Fiat system who is
not a carefully consciously or
deliberately designed Financial
operating system like Bitcoin rather it
evolved through a complex process of
compromise between political constraints
and experience
Bitcoin is a real asset and it is here
to stay and its maximum cap of 21
million makes it the scarcity asset on
Earth and ultimately the most attractive
asset listen to all the money managers
that praise it if we're right and
companies continue diverse to diversify
their cash into something like Bitcoin
and institutions institutional investors
start allocating five percent of their
funds we believe that the the price will
be tenfold
of where it is today so instead of 45
000 over 500 000. it's okay
the number one thing that I would
recommend to people is have some
defensive things in there I personally
think Bitcoin is a long-term hedge I
have a certain amount of money in
Bitcoin it's a small percentage of that
which I have in gold which is a
relatively small percentage of what I
have in my other asset classes and so on
and I think that that has the Merit I I
like Bitcoin as a portfolio diversifier
everyone always asks me what should I do
with my portfolio my employees say I say
okay listen the only thing that I know
for CERN is I want to have five percent
in Gold five percent in Bitcoin five
percent in cash five percent in
Commodities at this point in time I
don't know what I want to do with the
other eighty percent I do own some of it
and it's gone up a lot since I bought it
obviously the tone of this asset class
is changing well I think it's worth
considering all the uh the alternatives
to cash and all the alternatives to some
of the financial assets and so Bitcoin
has um has that is a possibility is that
America we had 26 percent more dollars
in circulation than over the past 244
years if you put the whole stimulus in
which it will happen that's another 16
percent more dollar formation uh so
you've got a 40 increase in dollar
volume that's going to show up in asset
prices
[Music]
when facts change I change I mean you
know I'm an investor the environment's
changing and what really uh turned me
was moves made by Regulators in
Switzerland where I'm an investor France
Germany England and then Canada opened
up they now have seven different
financial instruments trading on their
exchanges that holds the crypto as the
underlying which is a complete reversal
of what's occurred if you really
understand Bitcoin you'll recognize why
places like Morgan Stanley are coming
into the space it's a scarce asset and
as we were talking about last time I was
on the show that Supply demand imbalance
plus the impractibility of the
blockchain is going to make that asset
very attractive in a world printing
money like this it's it's an it's an
amazing accomplishment to have brought
it from where that programming occurred
to where it is and take the test of time
they've done this unbelievable marketing
job it's been around 13 years
and particularly younger Millennials
look at it the way I've always looked at
Gold I like Bitcoin right Bitcoin
is math and math has been around for
thousands of years and it two plus two
is going to equal four and it will for
the next 2 000 years so I like the idea
of investing in something that's
reliable consistent honest and 100
certain but I mean
foreign
because it's a way for me to invest in
certainty there's a country that uses
Bitcoin there's regions in Switzerland
where you can pay for your taxes in
Bitcoin there's a there's just this all
of this adoption and acceptance that is
happening around the world now even by
governments which just changes the the
rules and makes it more and more robust
the community makes it alive regardless
of political geopolitical and so on
situations the fact that governments are
themselves allowing the use of this in
whatever form or way confirms us
great ideas are beautiful and have great
power but like most beautiful things
they can also be more fragile than we
think
when I was a kid we thought about the
future and we were delighted by this
possibility we couldn't wait for it to
happen and be part of its creation
but now ask almost anyone what they
think about the future and they will say
something along the lines of nuclear war
climate catastrophe hunger pestilence
the death of life
we didn't took care of the beautiful
idea that we create our own future that
we as Humanity can do almost anything
that we imagine
our Ingenuity what separates us from
other species
in El Salvador we are trying to rescue
this idea and start the design of a
country for the future using the best
ingredients that makes us who we are
well uses sensibility to find the best
examples of ideas from history and
around the world
I believe Bitcoin could be one of these
ideas
that is why next week I will send to
Congress a bill that will make Bitcoin a
legal tender in El Salvador in the short
term this will generate jobs and help
provide Financial inclusion to thousands
outside the formal economy
the Bitcoin lawmakers in El Salvador
broke into Applause after voting to
approve Bitcoin as legal tender on
Wednesday making the Central American
country the first in the world to fully
adopt the cryptocurrency bitcoiners
around the world
the time has come
we are ready
this is an important step for our
country a step for technology a step
into the future to bring us Financial
inclusion investment tourism Innovation
and economic development to our country
buccali has even more ambitious plans
for Bitcoin saying later on Wednesday
that he wanted to use renewable energy
from the country's volcanoes to offer
Bitcoin mining facilities which generate
new units of the cryptocurrency and
instructed state-owned geothermal energy
firm laheo to come up with a plan to
make it happen the objective seems to be
making using Bitcoin as a actual medium
of payment medium of exchange much more
frictionless in the country eliminating
all capital gains taxes which is you
know of course a big impediment to
actually using this thing as a currency
uh you know potentially in service of
making uh you know Bitcoin based
remittances cheaper and less frictional
friends and so that seems to be sort of
the main thrust of the law what can we
extrapolate then uh as far as what the
future holds Beyond El Salvador here do
you think we'll see other I guess
legitimate countries like El Salvador
Embrace this and other larger countries
we know that Bitcoin cryptocurrency
stable coins have very high penetration
in places like Colombia and Argentina uh
you know Latin America is certainly no
stranger to Sovereign defaults or you
know periods of high inflation or
monetary repression so we see high
penetration there there's certainly a
class of policy makers that see an
opportunity to gain favor by signaling
their Affinity uh and uh you know we'll
see what happens but this is the first
El Salvador was the first non-paria
state to really legitimize and legalize
Bitcoin usage uh in in sort of its
intended way uh so you know it seems
like a big sea change frankly Banks as
opposed to governments banks are
businesses they sure have their own
personal interest at hand but they will
adapt to what their customers need and
they're adapting now actually they
realize that they need to be able to
offer some new financial services that
will be around crypto because they're
going to be left behind completely
because a guy like me a person like you
just won't need their services anymore
because all of this already exists in a
completely decentralized and
uncontrolled way according to crypto
firm I dig hundreds of U.S banks are
asking for Bitcoin planning to allow
customers to buy hold and sell the
digital currency through their existing
accounts as soon as this year for more
details let's bring in cnbc.com banking
reporter Hugh son Hugh what um had to
happen behind the scenes in order for
people to be able to access Bitcoin in
their Banks
hey hey Kelly nice to be with you so uh
there's a company called FIS and so uh
FIS is one of these uh you know back-end
providers Banks they actually have about
300 million in checking accounts through
their thousands of Bank clients and so
they service their Tech vendor that
serves a bunch of Banks and then there's
also a crypto a Bitcoin custody company
called naidig and they're one of the
companies like sort of a galaxy so 9dig
has a deal with Morgan Stanley for
instance to offer institutional funds to
their wealthy clients so you have some
nascent uh players joining some some
established Tech vendors you know FIS is
a 95 billion dollar company market cap
yeah and they basically said you know
we're gonna make it easy for people to
actually own Bitcoin it is after all a
financial asset and they want to they
want they've done studies that said
basically if people have the ability to
own Bitcoin through their existing
Financial relationship through the
portal that they deal with their other
money you know their their their uh Fiat
money and they able to do that you're
going to have greater adoption and so
basically what they're going to have is
they're going to as they turn this on
they're going to have access the clients
the customers of these community and
Regional banks that sign on for this
they're going to be able to go to their
Bank app and actually look inside their
Bank app and see crypto all right next
to their other deposits and they're
they're saving well we want to be in the
middle of any movement of funds and we
we don't try to decide what's going to
take off or not take off and we don't
pick winners and losers we just get
ready to enable whatever could possibly
happen and I think crypto is an exciting
Trend there are there's crypto
currencies which are kind of the digital
gold we think of uh Bitcoin and they are
what we're trying to do is create
utility uh which first of all allowing
making sure that our Visa cards are are
used to be able to purchase Bitcoin and
then when somebody wants to convert
their Bitcoin to a fiat currency uh used
to use a Visa credential to you go shop
at our 70 million Merchants around the
world so we're trying to create that
utility so we're working with 35 of the
biggest digital uh sorry the biggest
crypto uh wallets around the world
making sure that these uh various
digital currencies can be converted into
a fiat currency and that money can then
be spent uh from a Visa card in a wallet
and again at any one of our 70 million
Merchants around around the world
[Music]
we're at a point where markets are at
all-time highs uh any kind of ratio is
screaming that we're at the top of our
cycle we have companies that are that
are failing even now starting in China
and what happens is that all of this
money will have to exit the uh
Financial Market but there's huge
amounts of money now way more money uh
digitally in these assets than exists in
the pockets of every single person in
the world right so this money what tends
to happen when there's a you know top in
the market and the market is going to
drop of course there's loss of value so
all of these investors they need to get
their money out right they they always
do that because they don't want to lose
money their job
um and their mandate towards their
clients is to bring profits right not
losses so they're going to get their
money out of the of the financial
markets this of course will lead to an
even sharper job but this is standard it
happens at every cycle
now what tends to happen though is that
most investors at that point will uh get
into bonds which are uh government
obligations and these have interest
rates uh that are paid by the
governments but these interest rates
follow the interest rates that are set
by the central bank right so nowadays A
lot of these bonds are negative yielding
which means that if me as an investor I
want to have a certain return per year
even call it one percent today if I buy
a bond a European Bond I will not have
that because it's at a negative interest
rate so in fact it costs me to buy this
bond which until now was a secure uh
position for my money but would at least
bring at least bring me some returns now
even this fact isn't there right so in a
scenario where the money is pulled out
it cannot go to bonds because it is not
logical for it to be there because
there's just trust that is gone from
this value that governments use to be
able to hold in the long term with this
being gone this money where is it going
to go right it can go into gold but gold
um we've just seen we've just seen can
be controlled by governments has been
controlled by government and in the past
10 years hasn't increased in prices
that's the same price as 10 years ago
right so it's sure some money will go
into gold because it's a it's a it's a
typical kind of protection asset and
money will will transfer into gold
um but there is this uh this entire new
Financial Market that is being built at
the same time that is led by Bitcoin but
all of these other cryptocurrencies as
well Bitcoin is the first time ever in
history of Finance that's an asset
reaches this level valuation so quickly
on on top of that it is the technology
that is the most quickly adopted in the
world so before that it was the internet
that was adopted just I mean we've never
seen anything adopted so fast in terms
of adoption of a technological progress
right now the world of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is accelerating at a
faster rate than the internet which I
think makes sense because it speaks to
so many people in particularly uh
younger Generations rather than the
people that are in power that are of
older generations and so this Market of
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and I want
to really emphasize Bitcoin here because
Bitcoin is the the safe one that has all
of these applications that are being
built by other cryptocurrencies uh now
also built on the Bitcoin Network
meaning that for all of these funds that
have serious money and long-term
objectives
buying Bitcoin is one of the best trades
that they can have and given the
volatility that it has and the hedging
options that they can have represents a
lower risk for them than the traditional
assets that they're used to so this is
why I think and I'm not the only one in
thinking so uh Bitcoin will be the black
hole that will swallow a big part of all
of this money that will be escaping the
traditional markets because they will
just be no more value there no other
asset like this one has ever existed
before that marries our technological
progress with our financial systems it
is time for people to have a currency
that is as open and Anonymous as the
internet
with Bitcoin the control of money is
taken away from governments and given
back to the people
this removes huge power from governments
and their leaders that have had
countless issues with corruption abuse
of power or limiting our freedom we've
seen that our financial system needs a
reset and the only solution governments
have is to print trillions more it's
evaluating our currencies in the process
along the way they will continue to make
people more dependent on government
because welfare spending has to increase
to cover their irresponsible money
management
this provides governments with a
snowball effects Loop of inflation
leading to a poorer population leading
to more welfare spending leading to
increased government control
Bitcoin is the way out of their
controlled system that favors only the
wealthy and the elite
it is also the first time due to
incentives these people have for Bitcoin
to never succeed as a currency that
average people can front-run them and
grow their personal wealth first before
these people that consider themselves
the elite have a chance to do so
Bitcoin is slowly taken over the world
and will absorb a large amount of the
money currently stuck in our Legacy
Financial system
really want to be left behind with them
[Music]